[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
das grundrezept für einen leckeren
biscuit boden den könnt ihr am besten
für sahnetorten verwenden an zutaten
benötigen wir 616 eiweiß 150 gramm mehl
1 teelöffel backpulver eine prise salz
200 gramm zucker 50 gramm speisestärke
und je nach geschmacksrichtung den saft
einer zitrone oder vanille extrakt oder
wie ich ihn hier verwende vanillezucker
und den gebe ich schon direkt zu meinem
weißen zucker mit dazu
[Musik]
als erstes gebe ich das eiweiß in eine
rührschüssel mit meinem schneebesen
aufsatz gebe da die prise salz dazu und
starke dass drei minuten lang steif
[Musik]
dann gebe ich die hälfte des zuckers
hinzu und schlage das weitere drei
minuten lang
[Musik]
dann nehme ich mir mein eiweiß zur seite
und gäbe in die rührschüssel das eigelb
mit dem restlichen zucker
[Musik]
nach circa fünf minuten ist die eigelb
masse weiß cremig und dann gebe ich in
einzelnen schritten das eiweiß dazu
[Musik]
nachdem das eiweiß sorgfältig unter
gehoben wurde
sieben wir jetzt noch die trockenen
zutaten hinein mehlspeise stärke und
backpulver das wird noch einmal
sorgfältig unter gehoben und dann ist
der teig auch schon fertig und dieser
wird in eine 26 zentimeter springform
gefüllt einmal glatt gestrichen und dann
bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze für ca
40 minuten gebacken
der fertige biscuit boden kann jetzt
noch zweimal durchgeschnitten werden
unter dem schnell gehen muss für den
habe ich noch ein passendes blitz rezept
für einen biscuit boden